hello everybody welcome to vlog
university I'm so excited to make one of
the reason I'm probably the only prob
hello everyone and welcome to vlog
university i'm professor IJ or professor
i Justine if you will and I wanted to
thank all of you for submitting your
homework assignment the last episode of
Allah University the challenge was to
create a collab at music video now I
gave you guys some green screen clips of
my amazing dancing to work with and you
guys found some extremely creative ways
to use those cliffs probably one of my
favorites was this how to dance video
like Patrick worky 18 you how to be a
good dancer let's get started my
favorite thing about this video was the
awesome names that he gave my crazy
dance moves now this next video I might
be a little bit biased because I kinda
made a little cameo in it but it's by
Anna Sun kwiste and it is probably gonna
feature some of the best dance moves
you'll ever see in your life and so now
and I wanted to what are you feeling for
this for this vlog University what
should we do that going to do I should
ask I did it's a great idea you know a
lot of you to my suggestion from this
applaud university challenge would be to
have a dance party a dance play yes
a plus and here's a few other wonderful
music videos that you guys created that
I just had to feature in this episode I
met the lovely hey I j-dog here there
everywhere never been a fan of school
but hey boo boo who works a piece of
cake my videos what you gotta make don't
have to be great and don't worry about
the hey I just be created this for
videos is but she wants us to go down to
you apple store and get down on the
dance floor tell up i J thank you and
this is what we do oh if you want to see
all of the homework assignments that
were submitted for the last episode be
sure to check out to this link and it
will take you to see all of the video
responses that you guys made for that
video now for your next vlog university
challenge your homework assignments so I
know a lot of you guys have some secret
talents some talents that you might want
to portray here on the interwebs
replicate when people say interwebs I
need to never say that again here on the
internet so what I want you guys to do
is film yourself doing this special
talent maybe it's juggling maybe it's
painting maybe it's horseback riding or
frisbee throwing or you maybe I don't
know so my secret talent is juggling I'm
not amazing at it but it's been
something that I've been able to do
since I was really young and I really
like juggle
thank you guys so much for watching this
episode of log University don't forget
to submit your challenge videos below as
a video response to this video I can't
wait to see what you guys come up with
and see your secret talents of course be
safe and I love you and I'll see you
guys soon oh and don't forget to
subscribe
you